hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt eine dame mit orte und war
wollen wir als königin älter und ich wir
wollen dem papa eine freude machen denn
der murat der liebt diese kleinen ja
bonbons sind eigentlich schokoriegel
glaube ich kann man sie nennen und zwar
im innern ein karamell kern
ich habe mich noch mal zeigen oder
können zeigen so viel zeit muss sein
die finalisten karamell kern und außen
herum ist vollmilchschokolade hier sieht
man es auch ganz gut also wirklich
eigentlich sonst nichts anderes und es
gibt von allem mondi diese ganzen torten
also dein torte oder auch die mann
betreute die schwedische dich auch schon
mal gemacht habe wie findet ihr auch auf
meinen youtube kanal und heute geht es
dir gesagt die daran hat sie sich schon
länger mal gewünscht und im innern sind
drei teig böden und eine richtig leckere
creme was ganz tolles die ganze torte
ist lud ihn frei weil einfach gar kein
mehl und keine stärke verwendet wird und
ich würd sagen ich starte jetzt gleich
mit dem teig und zeigt euch mal die
zutaten für die freitag böden brauche
ich acht eiweiß eine prise salz 190
gramm zucker und streit im programm
haben ist nämlich zuerst das eiweiß und
das gebe ich jetzt in der küchenmaschine
ihr könnt aber auch zb mit einem
handrührgerät arbeiten
das ist jetzt stellt geschlagen werden
oder gäbe prise salz mit dazu das
zerstört die eiweißstoffe etwas
schneller
sobald das eiweiß steif ist lasse ich
jetzt den zucker ganz langsam ein rätsel
und es später für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten weiter gerührt damit sich das
sicher auch gut ausbilden kann
seit jetzt gleich wieder auf höchster
stufe aber in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr
euch schon mal zeigen was ich
vorbereitung fertig freibad papierbögen
und haben einen tortenring auf 24 cm
durchmesser eingestellt und jetzt zählt
die bögen um und zeichnet jeweils einen
kreis auf und war deswegen weil ich
später einfach ohne backform bankenwerte
der schnee ist es fertig und die
haselnüsse habe ich bereits im mai
kräftig treffer länder zerkleinerter so
dass mir jetzt fein gemahlen und die
kann ich jetzt unterheben
jetzt hätte ich sie ganz vorsichtig
unter und ich mal den ist immer gerne
selber weil sie einfach so viel
aromatischer schmecken als dieses thema
schon fein gemahlen kaufen kann
und die masse fühle jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel 1
und da habe ich vorne schon eine ganz
große loch thüle dran
ich hab mich spritzmittel zufolge macht
aber mit hilfe des sprits beutels und
der lochmühle könnt ihr jetzt die drei
bilden spritzen und zwar von außen
beginnen
und da hilft euch einfach diese
markieren wir gemacht hat
mit hilfe einer palette oder eines
messers candy teig bildenden
verstreichen
und jetzt werde ich alle freitag würden
backen und zwar im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 175 grad umluft da könnt ihr auf
jeden fall zwei bleche auf einmal
reinschieben
wenn euer backofen sec gut ist geht
sogar drei fläche auf einmal vor allem
wenn man diese lochbleche benutzt man
einfach die luft riss kurz dekodieren
kann und ich werde aber nur zwei
reinschieben war nicht die besten
backöfen habe
und die müssen dann für etwa 20 minuten
backen
während details würden jetzt noch backen
kann ich schon mal die creme zu bereiten
die muss ein bisschen abkühlen und die
creme ist ähnlich zu meiner damaligen
bequem dich für die an monty torte
gemacht habe und ich zeige euch mal die
flughafen für die creme rauchig 300
gramm schlagsahne 850 gramm zucker 3
esther haase museum oder likör und 275 g
weiche butter
nehmen wir auch mit der fr films perfekt
und baumharze justierung habe ich
übrigens einfach den wahrgenommen
die gibt es eigentlich in der
getränkeabteilung da fragen wir nicht
nimmt immer mal wieder welche als
zuschauer will ich nicht annehme und da
gibt es wirklich eine ganz große auswahl
bei getränkemärkten ich habe meine
übrigen von globus geholt ich nehme
jetzt die sahne und die kommt in einem
kleinen topf da kommt der zucker mit
dazu haseloff sirup jetzt muss ich die
mischung erwärmen
aber ich lasse nicht auftauchen also
wirklich nur kurz erwärmen auch
mittelbar hitze bis sich das zucker
aufgelistet
und sobald der zucker gelöst ist könnt
ihr das eigelb noch umgedreht so fühlt
es sich auch im blut in freier putin
also der tykwer 43 die führung des
briten frei
jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen von dieser
mission von der saane mischung mit
insights einfach damit so ein bisschen
die temperatur annimmt und nicht einfach
stockt jetzt und dann kommen jetzt die
ganze eigelb mischung hier wieder mit
zurück in den topf und will jetzt
gleichmäßig verrührt und es dauert etwa
fünf bis zehn minuten bis diese eier
masse auch ein bisschen fester wird und
stoppt sie darf wirklich nur ganz kurz
aufkochen und dann ist im prinzip auch
schon fett
die fertige creme fühle ich jetzt um
damit sie einfach ein bisschen schneller
abkühlt am besten immer in ein flaches
gefliest und entdecke ich direkt an der
oberfläche geschaltet wo ja damit sich
einfach keine haut bildet und die creme
muster auf zimmertemperatur abkühlen die
tortenböden kühl das thema temperatur ab
und die prozesse noch zimmertemperatur
und dann geht es weiter
jetzt geht's an den schönsten teilen wir
werden jetzt die torte füllen und
späteren festigen
ich habe hier fordern und was zutaten
für die fertigstellung brauche ich ein
bisschen schokolade und zwar die diamond
schokolade geht es einmal in kleiner und
großer verpackung 20 vom kokosfett 200
gramm vollmilch kuvertüre und das nette
zum tatort
ich werde zuerst einmal die weiche
butter inneres gegeben
die kann ich sind mir schon ein bisschen
schau mich an und in der zwischenzeit
nämlich jetzt die schokolade und die
werde ich dann mit einem messer einfach
so ein bisschen verkleinern
die schokolade sitzt grob zerkleinert
und jetzt nehme ich die abgekühlten
torte löwen und legt sie übereinander
und bette dann nochmal rund zurecht
dafür nehme ich jetzt noch mal meinem
tag ring und stellen ein bisschen
kleiner ein so dass ich einfach schöne
runde tortenböden bekomme ohne arbeit
zuviel wegzuschneiden umstand einfach
mit einem messer drum hatten
die toten sind jetzt zurecht geschnitten
jetzt kann ich die buttercreme weiter
und gebe jetzt von dem abgekühlten
pudding als von der masse jemand
esslöffel mit verweisen butter
jetzt kann die torte befüllt werden ich
hab den untersten boden jetzt auch ein
stück backpapier da kann ich später ein
bisschen einfacher auf eine tortenplatte
transportieren
und jetzt kommt ungefähr ein drittel der
creme hier auf den ersten boden
das bestreitet der palette
und anders als das original kommen jetzt
bei mir auch in die torte die beiden
stücke dann hab ich nämlich auch in
tatort ein bisschen krank und vor allem
diesen karabal mit
jetzt kommt der zweite tortenboden drauf
wird genauso gefüllt und dann kommt auch
beträgt deckel drauf
hier oben drauf kommt jetzt zuerst
einmal zuerst einmal eine dünne schicht
der buttercreme also dürfen nicht zu dem
natürlich ein bisschen sache schon sein
aber ich nehme es die hälfte vom rest
die top habe ich jetzt ganz schön
eingestrichen und stellt jetzt für etwa
15 bis 20 minuten in den kühlschrank bis
die butter themen einfach so ein
bisschen festwirt und dann kommt noch
die restliche buttercreme obendrauf
jetzt bestreite ich die torte noch mit
der restlichen creme und die riecht auch
wirklich toll also die theaterwelt
glaube ich im rat top bottom moritz
lieblingsorte in zukunft sein
die torte muss jetzt auch nicht ganz
perfekt glatt gestrichen werden denn die
allmende diamond orte die schon ein
bisschen ja das hat keine glatte
oberfläche sondern eher so eine
strukturierte und nehme ich die
restlichen stücke also der restlichen
stücke und die kommen jetzt noch so ein
bisschen unregelmäßig mit drauf
wenn die torte wird jetzt für etwa eine
halbe stunde eingefroren danach kann ich
sie mit core tier übergeben
die tat ist durch gekühlt und ich habe
sie bereits die kuvertüre geschmolzen
und temperiert das tempo ist ganz
wichtig damit die kuvertüre gleich einen
grauschleier bekommt und zwar habe ich
dafür die kuvertüre fein gehackt und in
drei teile eingeteilt und zwei teile
habe ich in einem heißen aber nicht mehr
kochende wasser bat geschmolzen und
sobald die quartiere geschmolzen ist
nimmt man sie vom wasserrad herunter
dann würde ich das restliche drittel mit
1 und auch das kokosfett dadurch wird
die kuvertüre ein bisschen flüssiger und
bekommt auch in kissing klamm und vor
allen dingen bricht sie später nicht
beim anschnitt
jetzt ist auch die restliche kuvertüre
darin geschmolzen und durch das
restliche drittel wird sie einfach
herunter gekühlt auf die perfekte
temperatur für die torte habe ich jetzt
hier was vorbereitet und zwar ein
abdruck gitter und strunz einmal ein
tablett damit die kuvertüre gleich
aufgefangen wird
mit sätzlich da die torte ohne
backpapier für mich drauf
und jetzt geh sich die flüssige form ich
kommentiere drüber
bei mir kommt so ein bisschen quartier
oben drauf dann verleiht bis hin zu
reden
da habe ich nochmal 200 gramm
geschmolzen und die gebe ich jetzt noch
mal hier auf dem rest mit drauf aber
wenn jetzt nur wollt dass die kuvertüre
am rande bühne finden natürlich auch nur
mit 200 gramm arbeiten
moralisch ist leider noch nicht dann
kann nicht probieren das spielt gerade
auch fußball geld deswegen darfst du
jetzt probieren alles klar
director da unten nicht hochsteigen
erzeugt so sagen der sparkurs soll damit
diese sportlich anhalt
so das messer mache ich es vorher beim
schneiden so ein bisschen warm da ich
eine dicke schutzschicht habe und damit
die einfach nicht
hallo ich maskat extra schön für die
jagd geht auf die toilette kommen wieder
zurück ist
hier ist die torte die sie doch richtig
lecker aus
drauf
hier sieht man diese drei teigschichten
die drei creme schichten und natürlich
die richtig leckere dicke schutzschicht
warum also was richtig toll ist weiter
ob ihr es gehört habt beim probieren
dieses sei es knackt so schönem und beim
kauen und schmeckt sie gut und ich bin
die tat es auch gar nicht so süß ist ein
bisschen fertig mit der butter aber ist
nichts schmeckt sehr lecker ist ein
gesundes rezept aber ein sehr leckeres
oder dem irak nichts mehr das heißt es
schmeckt dir anscheinend und ich hoffe
das wird natürlich damit demokrat mit
großen freude machen können machen wir
bestimmt erfreut sich bestimmte er
und falls er diese prozent machen wollt
dann geht auch sally - glock de versteht
es noch mal ganz genau für euch jetzt
gibt es nur an das hatte doch 100 100
prozent hat das von meinem papa schmeckt
der cappuccino ist also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal james spricht mit